- [Voiceover] So I have here
a three-dimensional graph,
and that means that it's representing
some kind of function that has
a two-dimensional input
and a one-dimension output.
So that might look
something like f of x, y
equals and then just some
expression that has a
bunch of x's and y's in it.
And graphs are great
but they're kinda clunky to draw.
I mean, certainly you can't
just scribble it down.
It typically requires some
kind of graphing software
and when you take a static image of it
it's not always clear what's going on.
So here I'm going to
describe a way that you can
represent these functions and
these graphs two-dimensionally
just by scribbling down on a
two-dimensional piece of paper.
This is a very common way
that you'll see if you're
reading a textbook or if someone
is drawing on a blackboard.
It's known as a contour plot
and the idea of a contour plot
is that we're going to take this graph
and slice it a bunch of times.
So I'm going to slice
it with various planes
that are all parallel to the x, y plane
and let's think for a moment
about what these guys represent.
So the bottom one here
represents the value z
is equal to negative two.
This is the z-axis over here
and when we fix that to be negative two
and let x and y run freely
we get this whole plane.
And if you let z increase,
keep it constant,
but let it increase by one to negative one
we get a new plane, still
parallel to the x, y plane
but it's distance from the
x, y plane is negative one.
And the rest of these guys,
they're all still constant values of z.
Now in terms of our graph,
what that means is that
these represent constant
values of the graph itself.
These represent constant
values for the function itself.
So because we always represent
the output of the function
as the height off of the x, y plane
these represent constant
values for the output.
What that's going to look like.
So what we do
is we say, "Where do these
slices cut into the graph?"
So I'm going to draw on all of the points
where those slices cut into the graph
and these are called contour lines.
We're still in three-dimensions
so we're not done yet.
So what I'm going to do is
take all these contour lines
and I'm going to squish them
down on to the x, y plane.
So what that means,
each of them has some kind
of z component at the moment,
and we're just going to chop it down,
squish them all nice and flat,
on to the x, y plane.
And now we have something two-dimensional,
and it still represents
some of the outputs of our function.
Not all of them, it's not perfect,
but it does give a very good idea.
I'm going to switch over to
a two-dimensional graph here.
And this is that same
function that we were just looking at.
Let's actually move it a
little bit more central here.
So this is the same function
that we were just looking at, but
each of these lines represents
a constant output of the function
so it's important to realize
we're still representing
a function that has a
two-dimensional input
and a one-dimensional output.
It's just that we're
looking in the input space
of that function as a whole.
So this is still
f of x, y
and then some expression of those guys
but this line might represent
the constant value of f
when all of the values
were at outputs three.
Over here, this also,
both of these circles together give you
all the values where f outputs three.
This one over here
will tell you where it outputs two
and you can't know this just
looking at the contour plot
so typically if someone's drawing it
if it matters that you
know the specific values
they'll mark it somehow.
They'll let you know what
value each line corresponds to
but as soon as you know that
this line corresponds to zero
it tells you that every
possible input point
that sits somewhere on this line
will evaluate to zero when you
pump it through the function.
And this actually gives a very good feel
for the shape of things.
If you like thinking in terms of graphs
you can kind of imagine how
these circles and everything
would pop out of the page.
You can also look,
notice how the lines are really
close together over here,
very, very close together,
but they're a little
more spaced over here.
How do you interpret that?
Well, over here this means it
takes a very, very small step
to increase the value
of the function by one,
very small step and it increases by one,
but over here it takes a much larger step
to increase the function
by the same value.
So over here this kind of means steepness.
If you see a very short
distance between contour lines
it's going to be very steep
but over here it's much more shallow.
And you can do things like this
to kind of get a better feel
for the function as whole.
The idea of a whole bunch
of concentric circles
usually corresponds to
a maximum or a minimum,
and you end up seeing these a lot.
Another common
thing people will do with contour plots
as they represent them is color them.
So what that might look like
is here where
warmer colors like orange
correspond to high values
and cooler colors like blue
correspond to low values.
The contour lines end up going along
the division between red and green here,
between light green and green,
and that's another way were
colors tell you the output and then
the contour lines
themselves can be thought of
as the borders between different colors.
And again a good way to get a feel
for a multi-dimensional function
just by looking at the input space.